[Música]
[Aplausos]
todos tenemos un eros en la vida una
persona que nos inspira a ser mejores
personas una persona con la que nos
queremos convertir nuestro ejemplo a
seguir vaya para mí esa persona es
carlos freire o sea mi abuelo me enseñó
desde chiquita a vencer mis miedos más
grandes como por ejemplo el mar también
es de chiquita me da muchísimo muchísimo
miedo el mar pero mi abuelo nació en
veracruz entonces no había cosa más
natural que para él que el mar una vez
fuimos de vacaciones a barra potosí que
es una playita chiquita en ixtapan y me
acuerdo que yo me quedé viendo el margen
grande desafiante temeroso y pensé yo
nunca me voy a meter ahí no gracias paso
me gusta mucho mi vida y mi abuelo al
verme tan espantada me dijo como como no
te vas a meter está padrísimo yo te voy
a cuidar te la vas a pasar súper bien y
nos vamos a meter ya entonces accedí y
voy caminando con mi abuelo así por la
playa cuando de repente de esta ola
enorme enfrente de mí que según el
momento nada tan grande pero yo era muy
pequeña
pues entendí que en ese momento ya no
había nada más que poder hacer así que
se revisó ojos muy fuertemente y espere
el impacto de esta ola seguro ya saben
cómo fueron los siguientes segundos yo
bajo el agua la ola revolcando me harán
entrando me por todos lados dijo sin
embargo que lo que más me acuerdo en ese
momento fue como sentí las manos de mi
abuelo sosteniendo me los brazos muy
fuertemente sin dejarme ir
el año pasado yo me voy a estudiar a la
alemania con una amiga y en los primeros
meses que estuve ahí mi abuelo se empezó
a poner más le iban a realizar una
operación que aparentaba ser sencilla
pero terminó en cáncer así que mi héroe
mi abuelo perdió esa batalla
me acuerdo que estaba con mi amiga jean
como las 4 de la mañana en alemania
estamos en mi cuarto pero yo siempre
estuve al pendiente de todo lo que le
estaba sucediendo a mi abuelo cuando de
repente recibo la llamada que menos
quería recibir me marca mi papá y me
dice hola mi amor hoy estoy aquí en el
cuarto con tu abuelo y la verdad es que
no se ve nada bien estar consciente pero
no puede hablar y no sabemos cuánto
tiempo le quede así que esta es tu
chance para despedirte
cuando mi papá me dijo esas palabras
hasta la fecha no puedo explicar lo que
sentí fue como si una parte de mí
también se hubiera muerto como se supone
que le diría a una de las personas que
más amaba en este planeta adiós en tan
sólo unos segundos y sin la oportunidad
de abrazarlo siquiera sostener la mano y
darle las gracias por todo lo que había
hecho por mí
todos los recuerdos que tenía con mi
abuelo pasaron un abrir y cerrar de ojos
pero recuerdo que tenía más presente fue
el que les conté a su momento aquí
estaba yo fue matt otra vez para de
enfrente al estado la que parece hacer
un millón de veces más grande solamente
que ésta desbol taba y no estaba mi
abuelo para sostenerme
una semana después y me marca a mis
papás y me dicen que se tuvieron que
llevar a mi tía a urgencias porque le
hicieron una operación mal en la columna
y se le infectó estuve en terapia
intensiva durante tres meses y ella
estuvo a punto de morir fue como si otra
ola hubiera llegado a ahogarme aún más
yo no podía con la idea de que podía
perder posiblemente alguien más que
amaba con todo mi corazón
yo me veía en la necesidad de escapar de
escaparme de esta realidad aunque fuera
por un poquito se supone que mi tía yo
íbamos a viajar juntas por europa pero
dadas las circunstancias eso no se pudo
así que le marca esta paz y les dije que
quería viajar sola mi papá se
sorprendieron muchísimo porque soy una
niña bastante tímida y me dio medios y
no me creyeron capaz de hacerlo
así que para muchas personas viajar solo
es algo emocionante hasta desafiantes
pero para mí era el sinónimo de miedo
miedo a perder me voy a hablar con gente
desconocida miedo a reconocer que tenía
muchísimo miedo
así que sin pensarlo compré mi boleto y
un viaje se convirtieron en muchos
cada vez que estaba sola en algún
aeropuerto en algún tren o en algún
avión comenzaba a pensar que las
pérdidas no solo son dolor y sufrimiento
hay mucho más que eso
las pérdidas te abren las puertas a
nuevas oportunidades y misión adaptarme
a una nueva realidad
cuando estaba en alemania tuve la
fortuna de vivir en la playa persona
foto donde yo vivía
y cada vez que iba me acordaba muchísimo
de mi abuelo era casi casi como si fuera
a visitarlo
y comencé a pensar las cosas de la
siguiente manera comencé a imaginarme
que la vida es como el mar y que las
pérdidas son como las olas acepte la
idea de que a lo largo de nuestra vida
nos vamos a enfrentar con muchísimas
pérdidas
comencé a pensar que algún momento nos
llegaría esta gran y desafiante ola pero
que no lo teníamos que tener miedo esta
ola ni al sufrimiento ya que no durará
para siempre llegaron entonces a volar
no nos ahogar porque está nuestro
instinto sobrevivir
esas son las olas que nos marcan y que
nos hacen más fuertes y maduras la
pérdida de mi abuelo me trajo valentía
de salir al mundo me trajo la valentía
de hacer una teta y pararme bien frente
a todos ustedes
gracias a la pérdida de mi abuelo
aparece muchísimo más las personas que
están a mi alrededor porque no se conoce
la última vez que las voy a ver
hay una frase que me gusta mucho del
maestro zen john kabát zinn y dice tal
vez no podemos evitar que las olas
vengan pero podemos aprender a montar
las tienes un pensamiento que me libera
todos los días
muchísimas muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]